ce sont des moments du quotidien et
presque anodin et qui sans paradis ne
les a jamais eu temps précieux ceux de
l'adaptation encore songe merci de ce
qui pouvait se passer dans l'actualité
décret et c'est lui qui a choisi de ne
pas solliciter un quatrième mandat
mais difficile de lâcher prise les
souvenirs sont encore frais et jamais
très long c'est celle où vous étiez tout
temps pendant dix ans c'est seul que je
t'aime pendant deux heures puis le yom
une plaque de cheveux il est même parti
avec la chaise du parlement où il a
défendu les politiques de stephen harper
mais symbole de démocratie et de rigueur
lien pour jeune discipline oui je peux
vous et qui en incarne à vapeur parce
que c'était quelqu'un de très très très
rigoureux intellectuellement un premier
ministre à son avis sur protéger combien
de fois christian paradis aurait aimé
discuter en tête à tête du dossier du
québec avec son patron souvent la porte
était fermée bien gardé par son
entourage
il y avait un filtre carrément un jeu ça
frustre et là c'est sûr que c'est
frustrant mais je me dis il y avait des
solutions l'époque pour le bo avait
beaucoup de 3 beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
trop à mon avis trop avait absolument
il ne blâme pas son chef pour qui il
aura toujours le plus grand des respects
mais plutôt sa garde rapprochée il ya eu
des gens extraordinaires avec qui j'ai
pu travailler appuyait mobile y en a
d'autres avec qui est vraiment c'était
les douze travaux d'astérix où jour
après jour faut préserver l'image ne
sera plus important celui qui est chef
c'est lui qui draine d'avoir jeu
compréhension mais si on y voit un point
tel qu'ils en nombre h sur l'équipe
qu'on est une gamme gao ning
selon lui c'est une culture qui a nui au
développement du parti conservateur au
québec
une frustration où j'avais juin puis je
lance l'appel aux prétendants à la
chefferie
il faut s'occuper de montréal c'est la
deuxième plus grosse bulle au canada
justement l'ancien ministre tony clément
est un des 99 survivants conservateur
qui forme l'opposition officielle
ce n'est pas un hasard si on a pu le
rencontrer à montréal
il mesure ses chances il songe
sérieusement à briguer la direction du
parti conservateur mais d'abord sa
lecture de la campagne électorale bien
sûr le campagne électorale c'est trop
long en dix semaines de campagne 3 qui
conservateurs ont explosé leurs
faiblesses leurs forces
le bilan économique du gouvernement a
été selon lui brouillé par des textes
est dépassé
pour ne pas dire gênante vous êtes à
l'aise avec ça j'ai essayé de ne pas
regarder parce que j'ai ce qu'on peut
faire
il faut maintenant tourner la page
parler de l'avenir avoir des relais
politiques qui moche mieux parce que
quatre mois après la défaite et moult
réflexions tony clément passe aux aveux
c'est ridicule n'est que la partie que
la part des politiques faut améliorer le
portier donc chaque fois que vous ou
votre chef élevées pour dire 'nous
réforme pour 6 et pour ça ça aide à
combattre la pauvreté
vous vous rendez compte que vous êtes
est complètement dans che c'est clair
maintenant c'est pas clair il y a 6 mois
est-ce qu'il faut ramener le parti à
gauche un peu à gauche toi tu sais qui
c'est mais ça a été important
alors c'est important pour la 20ème
siècle pour le 21 21 6 est requis c'est
que ça l'exemple de et ministre de
l'immigration quand il a été défait à
l'automne en pleine controverse sur les
réfugiés
lui aussi a des regrets le regret de
n'avoir pas annoncé
notre initiative pour répondre à la
crise en syrie plus tôt après les photos
d'aller sur la plage
pourtant il est allé au front pour
défendre les politiques des
conservateurs
aujourd'hui la firme qu'il se battait en
coulisses contre les stratèges et
c'était pas une priorité
l'accueil des réfugiés syriens pour tout
le monde au sein de notre campagne
électorale j'étais en train de pousser
pour des chiffres plus important de
réfugiés syriens en automne 2013
il aura fallu deux semaines pour que les
conservateurs annoncent de nouvelles
mesures je pense que cela a fait quelque
chose
a laissé une impression est très
dangereuse chez les gens qu'on n'était
plus le gouvernement conservateur
accueillant il croit aussi que le débat
sur le port du niqab est allé beaucoup
trop loin et c'est l'oeuvre des
stratèges apparemment comme ses
confrères il a marché ou pas les gens me
reprochent d'avoir été partisan non
j'étais le partisan oui de mon parti
mais passionné par tout ce que tout ce
qui représente le canada
l'ancien diplomate que plusieurs
voyaient un jour à la tête du parti
conservateur encaissé la défaite
et son retour en politique n'est qu'une
question de temps j'ai mis un croire sur
l'analyse et toutes les tortures de soi
même qu'on peut faire je suis tourné
vers l'avenir
et comme ses collègues il est convaincu
que 6000 râpeux passera à l'histoire
comme un grand premier ministre malgré
les critiques et son style austère mais
pour christian paradis son départ
presque en silence de la scène politique
demeure une énigme
je comprends vos gens charmants
quand je suis parti mais je remercie mes
électeurs des canadiens pourquoi mettre
à profit un plein y est toujours député
chaque fois pour parler pour lui je n'ai
seulement pour vous
un peu oui un peu